on
va plus loin avec un mais côté
l'historien françois durpaire bonjour
françois argent affaires et bruno daroux
de la rédaction de france 24 dont george
russell même le pape françois hun sen
mail le souverain pontife juge venu le
temps de dire ça suffit au trafic
incontrôlée des armes à feu aux
etats-unis le débat sur la circulation
des armes est donc relancé dans un pays
où deux visions s'affrontent écouter
l'entraîneur des golden state warriors
l'équipe de basket suivi du sénateur
républicain du texas tech cruz
et secours
quand il y à des meurtres comme ça on
voit des politiciens essayer de les
politiser on voit les démocrates et des
gens dans les médias qui ont comme seule
solution est d'essayer de restreindre
les droits constitutionnels des citoyens
respectueux des lois elles ne marchent
pas c'est inefficace ça ne prévient pas
l'écrire
on a été deux cousins l'appeler même à
davantage de policiers armés autour des
établissements scolaires et même à armer
les enseignants françois durpaire c'est
ça cet énorme écart finalement qui
explique la paralysie des états unis sur
cette question le fait que le pays soit
6 polarisée
oui raphaël et j'ai même l'impression
que l'on prend le problème à l'envers
dans nos analyses c'est là que depuis le
départ la de faim après la tragédie ont
dit fin je parle de l'ensemble de la
presse mondiale et des réactions
c'est toujours la même chose est ce que
les démocrates vont enfin pouvoir faire
passer une loi est ce que ça va passer
et puis on a une sorte de fatalisme et
on a l'impression que notre fatalisme
c'est presque le pire du pessimisme sauf
que le pire c'est pas que les démocrates
n'arrivent pas à faire passer un jour
une loi
restreignant le port d'armes c'est pas
ça qui est en train de se passer ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est que le
maigre et fort que certains états
démocrate et bien
le maigre et fort qu'ils ont pu faire
est en passe de se détricoter je veux
dire que est ce que dans quelques temps
il va pas y avoir plus d'état dans la
direction du texas que d'état dans la
direction du new jersey ou dans l'état
de new york pourquoi je dis ça mais
parce qu'on va avoir une décision de la
cour suprême bientôt vous savez que la
cour suprême en 2008 a dit eh bien il
faut interpréter le deuxième amendement
de manière individuelle et c'est pas lié
à l'histoire d'être lié à une milice
voilà donc on est protégé par le
deuxième amendement chaque individu a le
droit de porter une arme aux états unis
d'amérique l'état de new york 10 et à sa
suite hawaï et à sa suite la californie
et à sa suite le nude gers et les étapes
progressiste 10 il faut un permis aux
porter une arme et l'état a le droit de
demander à l'individu pourquoi il veut
porter pourquoi il veut porter une arme
et donc on lui donne le permis si cette
raison est valable hélas la cour suprême
est ce qu a dit déjà le chief justice
roberts c'est que ça c'était
inacceptable c'est à dire que les
individus les citoyens américains ne
doivent la liberté d'un citoyen
américain à porter son arme ne doit pas
être conditionné à rien du tout c'est à
dire vous avez droit au deuxième
amendement c'est donc ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que dans quelques la
encablures là vous pouvez avoir l'état
de new york le new jersey tous ces états
là qui recule donc pas demandez pas je
sais qu'il ya eu de la gesticulation
politique depuis 24 heures barack obama
joe biden qui dit vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir les élections mi terme
on va peut-être avoir une super majorité
on va finir par y arriver etc mais là on
n'est pas là dessus on est sur des lois
qui risque d'être détricoté par la cour
suprême qui vous savez est à majorité
conservatrice dont on est déjà parlé et
il en est du port d'armes comme de droit
à l'avortement on voit que le fond du
débat se résume comme souvent aux états
unis à des questions juridiques
c'est-à-dire d'interprétation de la
constitution restrictives ou dans une
approche disons constructiviste on n'a
rien appris de sandy hook c'est à dire
que des événements comme ceux là ne font
pas bouger les lignes évoluer l'opinion
y compris de ce parti le parti
républicain qui se pose aujourd'hui en
protecteur de ce deuxième amendement
danser dans son acception la plus la
plus stricte mais il ya des choses il ya
d'abord la la fracture philosophie que
vous avez extrêmement bien montré dans
les deux interventions c'est à dire
qu'on ne peut pas on peut pas et qui
sommes-nous pour douter de l'émotion de
tête crous quand il voit ces images ou
de n'importe quel républicain on a
l'impression d'en france que tous les
conservateurs américains sont des
monstres absolue qui n'aiment pas leurs
enfants il en tire des conclusions
différentes de nous européens oui ils se
disent il faut comme l'état de floride
qui dit et qui le fait parce que là il
le dit être cous attention il faut plus
mais en floride c'est déjà fait en
floride les enseignants ont droit à
porter des âmes vous et vous rappeler de
ce qu'ont dit les syndicats enseignants
et syndicats enseignants dits problèmes
qu'on ne peut pas bien mais je suis pas
en train de dire que ça posera problème
ça pose problème ils ont dit quoi et
syndicats on peut pas enseigner et se
former à des tireurs d'élite parce qu'on
n'est pas formé à réagir ad ar 15 ça
c'est vous savez les fameuses armes de
guerre et la deuxième chose c'est que
tout est une question pas seulement de
constitution et pas seulement de
philosophie la vraie question c'est une
question de business il ya 20 ans on
produisait 4 millions d'armes de poing
dans ce pays les états unis d'amérique
aujourd'hui on au produit 11 millions ça
veut dire que derrière la nra il ya une
industrie qui vend ces armes qui fait
croire aux américains qu'ils ont besoin
d'armes de guerre pour donner une image
c'est comme si on faisait croire je ne
sais pas n'importe quel une industrie
automobile faisait croire qu'on avait
besoin de formule 1 pour aller prendre
s'est fait refaire cicm ans donc dire
aux américains pour faire du sport un
tir et au ball-trap ou aller faire de la
sache la chasse vous avez besoin
d'une arme qui est une arme de
destruction qu'on utilise que sur deux
théâtres de guerre là il ya vraiment un
problème méthodologique mais qui ne peut
s'expliquer que par l'appât du gain que
par le business et c'est pour ça que la
nra distribuer les bons points à plus
pour ted cruz
si ledit de travers il aura à où il le
rap et il sera pas réélu du coup à
l'appel de joba et de nos réactions à ce
carnage apparaît bien incantatoire
écouter
pourquoi acceptons-nous de vivre avec
ces carnages pourquoi continuons-nous a
laissé faire
oui pour l'amour de dieu notre courage
d'y faire face et de tenir tête aux
lobbies
il est temps de transformer cette
douleur en ac pour chaque parent pour
chaque citoyen nous devons faire
comprendre à tous les élus de ce pays
qu'il est temps d'agir et trimbach
joe biden à bruno dao qui promet
d'affronter le lobby des armes or la nra
tient son congrès ce vendredi en fin de
semaine précisément au texas à houston
en présence du gouverneur de l'état on
va dire l'entendre dans un instant greg
abbott et vous allez réagir juste après
gander une personne qui tire sur de
petits enfants
c'est intolérable
c'est inacceptable pour nous d'avoir
dans cet état quelqu'un qui tue des
enfants dans nos écoles
tous les texans partage le deuil des
familles tous valdes et
les gens ont le droit d'être en colère
après ce qui s'est passé
ça c'est le greg abbott d'aujourd'hui
d'il ya environ une heure et puis il ya
un autre greg abbott qui dans deux jours
sera en théorie présents au congrès de
la nra l'on peut évidemment s'étonner de
cette concordance de dates lui-même sans
doute n'y est pas pour grand chose en
fait comment va-t-il justifier sa
présence bruma parce que effectivement
pour le coq au musée françois que c'est
parce qu'ils sont approuvés ou pas
prouvé son nom des logiciels différents
c'est à dire que pour quelqu'un comme
oui ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui est
intolérable parce que c'est la personne
qui est parti en vrille si vous me
passez l'expression qui est qui a fauté
c'est pas la question de l'armée et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs certains
républicains effectivement propose que
les enseignants du clic et ils disent il
faudrait plus d'armes est vrai que les
enseignants puissent avoir des armes ou
qu ils sont dans cette logique donc je
pense que il ira peiné à ce congrès de
la nra mais qu'il va rester sur sa
position comme beaucoup de républicains
finalement oui ce qui semble d'autant
plus absurde que c'était qu'un certain
nombre de républicains s'opposent même à
la vérification des antécédents
psychiatriques des porteurs d'armes
alors là il n'y a plus aucune excuse
vous avez mis le doigt dessus c'est à
dire que on peut pas on peut pas
contester que greg abbott est le même
homme qui est laid réellement ému et
celui qui a deux ans met en place enfin
qui dit il n'y aura plus de permis à
partir de 21 ans vous avez tous des
armes et vous pouvez même avoir une arme
à l'université si vous êtes étudiant
mais là vous mettez le doigt quand même
sur quelque chose d'une contradiction
c'est à dire que les républicains disent
effectivement et ça c'est très
intéressant de dire il faut aller
chercher du côté de la maladie mentale
delà du trouble psychiatrique du trouble
psychologique surtout pour des musées
demain parce que si on regarde les
derniers temps les dernières fusillades
a deux filles cela dit une fois la c1 18
ans 20 exactement et quelques années les
adolescents et d'ailleurs quand ils
arrivent en lui la l'impression de tuer
tous ceux qui l'ont isolé dans sa
théorie à sept ans et demi bon et bien
évidemment qu'il faut aller chercher du
côté de la maladie psychiatrique ou même
de ses enfants de ces adolescents qui
sont qui sont en perdition
moral mais
ça veut dire qu' il faudrait les mettre
dans des hôpitaux psychiatriques
c'est ce que disent les les républicains
en revanche on a droit de leur vendre
des armes de guerre alors là je
l'analyse s'arrête là on a du mal à
comprendre comment ils défendent sa
série 10 c'est un problème les
gauchistes veulent nous interdire les
armes non il faut mettre le paquet sur
la maladie mentale et les mettre en
hôpital psychiatrique comme c'était le
cas avant les années 60 quand tout
démonter un c'est ce que disent les
prêts conservateurs américains sont fox
news et compagnie mais en même temps
quand vous leur dites bon à minima avant
d'être en hôpital psychiatrique faudra
au moins déjà leur interdire les armes
de guerre non et ils s'opposent à la
recherche des antécédents et au fait que
le fbi puis savoir 24 heures 48 heures
peut-être 70 12 heures pour vérifier au
moins parce que ce sont tous des digital
natives à 18 ans ils sont nés dans le
net il annoncé sur facebook c'est qu'il
voulait s'en prendre à une école
primaire oui et il avait même posté ces
armes et celui d'il ya dix jours disait
c'est bizarre le fbi haima pas attraper
et pourtant il a laissé tellement de
traces sur les réseaux sociaux qui s'en
étonnaient lui même donc là ça ça on ne
peut pas comprendre ça
merci françois durpaire on vous retrouve
la semaine prochaine jeudi prochain
comme chaque jeudi d'ordinaire pour on
va pouvoir y ait un petit changement
cette semaine qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
de notre fait merci beaucoup à tous
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
dans l'actualité aussi la publication du
rapport sous grez rendu sur les soirées
arrosées a organisée à downing street du
temps les britanniques étaient eux
confiné pour cause de coheed le rapport
crime et durement en cause le premier
ministre boris johnson et son entourage
et conclut même par cette sentence les
hauts dirigeants qu'ils soient
politiques ou officielles doivent
assumer la responsabilité de cette
culture écoutez la réaction de boris
johnson aujourd'hui
cela m'a rendu humble j'ai appris la
leçon
quelles que soient les erreurs commises
par le thème darling street et mon
cabinet lors de cette période difficile
a admis que j'admire d'ailleurs j'en
assume l'entière responsabilité
je continue à croire que les
fonctionnaires et les conseillers en
question sont des travailleurs acharnés
motivée par l' envie de faire de leur
mieux pour notre pays
le rapport bruno daroux et et est
accablant pour brunson oui à leur apport
de sucres et il est assez accablant pour
hbo johnson d'abord parce que non pas
qu'on apprenne vraiment des choses
nouvelles sur la date des soirées etc
mais ce qu'on apprend c'est le nombre de
participants il y avait entre 30 et 40
participants ce qu'on apprend aussi
c'est que alors sous grez ne cite pas de
noms mais elle dit que forcément c'est
les hautes strates les 10 downing street
qui était au courant de ce genre de
soirée ce qui va à l'encontre de ce qu'a
dit boris johnson devant la chambre des
communes où disait que il pose pas été
pas forcément au courant de ces soirées
il passait comme ça une tête est resté
dix minutes etc il ya d'ailleurs une
enquête parlementaire qui est encore en
cours pour mensonge devant le parlement
ce qui est extrêmement grave dans la vie
politique et juridique britannique met
donc trente à quarante participants des
soirées visiblement là il ya des détails
très alcoolisés au point que l'on
conseille participants tardivement de
sortir par la porte de derrière au point
qu'il ya eu des altercations donc on a
on a beaucoup de détails les
altercations entre gens un peu éméché
comme ça arrive des comportements
inappropriés vis-à-vis des agents de
sécurité ou des agents de nettoyage tout
ça donne l'impression d'une comme elle
l'écrit d'ailleurs su gré d'une culture
un peu une culture de l'impunité comme
reproché le leader travailliste
d'ailleurs on ne peut pas faire la loi
et la violer juste après où en même
temps donc voilà une culture de
l'impunité presque de l'arrogance aussi
est donc évidemment ça fait un très
mauvais effet mais johnson lui il
continue à dire qu'il a retenues elles
sont vous l'avez entendu et que
maintenant il faut passer à autre chose
il a réformé son équipe à downing street
s'attaquer aux vrais problèmes du pays
l'inflation galopante la guerre en
ukraine il veut regarder vers le futur
et il sait que pour l'instant à
l'intérieur de son parti il n'y a pas
suffisamment de députés mécontents pour
le mettre réellement en danger via une
procédure de destitution politiquement
et donc il peut tenir d'autant que en la
politique et à court terme moyen
l'adversaire n'est pas lui-même exemple
justement de reproches ou en tout cas de
difficulté oui monsieur alors qu'hier
starmer là évidemment sauf que car
starmer lui n'a pas fait la loi enfin il
n'a pas été non plus idéal on va dire
dans l'application de ces règles parce
qu'alors outre-manche on appelle ça le
bill gates apparemment il a il a bu des
bières et manger du poulet au curry avec
ses équipes pendant des périodes de
confinement mais il est quand même pas
tout à fait dans la même position en
fait pour l'instant beau et johnson qui
est vraiment un rock qui tient bon veut
rester au pouvoir c'est tout ce qui
compte visiblement pour lui c'est le
pouvoir y rester à tout prix absolument
pas démissionner et il va voir ensuite
dans les mois qui viennent comment ça se
passe à l'intérieur de son parti mais il
faudra regarder aussi de très près
comment il réussit notamment à lutter
contre l'inflation alors il est très en
pointe dans la guerre en ukraine parce
que aussi il sait que politiquement sont
partis à cause de lui fragilisé et donc
ça à tout moment si par les hopla lutte
contre l'inflation et pas efficace et
qu' il ya un vrai mécontentement
populaire il a beaucoup misé dans les
sondages bien là il ya des membres de
son parti il en suffit de 54 qui
pourrait à ce moment-là lancer la
procédure de destitution mais pour le
moment ce soir il peut encore dormir
tranquille au 10 downing street cette
bonne ville il est une heure de moins au
royaume-uni encore dans le match sans
doute pas de soirées alcoolisées ce soir
merci bruno daroux c'était on va plus
loin on se retrouve dans trois minutes
pour un nouveau journal dans pareils
actes
[Musique]